il s'agit d'un projet qu'on a appelé EDF
Lab Paris-Saclay c'est un projet qui
illustre en fait les deux piliers de
développement du groupe PDF avec d'une
part le développement des compétences et
l'autre pilier et la recherche et
l'innovation puisque sur le site dans
vos voyelles chantier derrière vous vous
allez avoir à la fois un centre de
formation qui va être le premier centre
de formation des DF en Europe et
également le plus grand centre de
recherche et développement du groupe
nous attiré ici c'est la capacité de
recherche et d'innovation que va
constituer demain le regroupement de
centres de recherche publique et
d'enseignement supérieur et de recherche
de premier plan
c'est la première fois qu'on construit
un site de cet envergure et surtout
c'est une première au sens où on
rapproche la formation et la recherche
et développement de façon à développer
les synergies entre ces deux fonctions
qui constitue pour nous également une
première c'est de s'implanter sur un
campus scientifique et technique de
cette ampleur là avec le regroupement de
l'ensemble des établissements qui vont
constituer l'université Paris-Saclay on
aura un des 10 premiers campus mondial
et ça bien sûr c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait unique
on va accueillir ici des populations
extrêmement diverses d'abord sur le site
de la recherche et développement nous
aurons à la fois aller chercheurs EDF
mais aussi des chercheurs du monde
académique des thésards des stagiaires
et tout ça va se mettre en place au
travers d'un ensemble architectural qui
permettra au travers de bâtiments situés
en zone ouverte c'est-à-dire sans
contrôle d'accès d'avoir une interaction
forte entre les populations
la réussite de de Paris-Saclay elle
viendra justement du transfert vers le
marché d'un certain nombre d'innovations
qui naîtront dans l'élaboratoires
académiques et quelque part la recherche
industrielle et une sorte de passeur
entre les résultats du monde académique
et puis les métiers soit les métiers
dans les dans les grands groupes soit le
marché et donc je pense que on aura
demain sur Paris l'ensemble des
ingrédients pour faire en sorte que la
mayonnaise prenne et que la réussite
économique les sorts économique soit au
rendez-vous de campus de Paris Saclay